you are at war with mary anne from
brooklyn she has a matter with you
i got mad at her for throwing super
spreader events but she appears to be
very nasty she won't drop it chris
looked at my instagram in october about
the super spread or whatever you want to
say you did it but chris did chris had
to tell you that
he was in your ear because before chris
we never had a problem ralph and you
know it
marianne your post was on instagram
it was on public instagram everyone saw
it not just me
who is friends and who is enemy now
chris and ralph are still
friends marianne are you friends with
ralph or
you're against ralph i like ralph very
much and i feel very bad about it chris
i'll never like
i i rather
can i just say marion might have a point
i was a lovely person before chris came
along
well that was true ronnie the limo
driver
thinks that ralph has cut him out of his
life and he doesn't think ralph
considers him a friend anymore
they asked me off air about this and i i
explained the situation ronnie why are
you yelling at me
i'm not yelling i'm just telling you
what's going on ronnie are you friends
with him or not i don't know what's
going on
friends we haven't talked in ever since
this whole [ __ ] started so
you know i guess i just want to know i
want to
i never said i wasn't his friend okay
did he ever say that
i'm asking him to say that i'm asking
you
are you friends with ralph well no i'm
not friends with somebody who's not my
friend
you just said you're not friends with
him you did something
i'm assuming i'm not friends with him
because that's what he stated
okay wait a second two seconds ago you
said have i ever said i'm not friends
with ralph and now you're saying you're
not friends why are you breaking my
[ __ ] balls about it
because i want to know what's going on i
want to know are you friends with
what's going on
i was asked the question by somebody on
the staff i answered the question
i feel ralph doesn't want to be my
friend and i said that's how he feels
that's fine i have no help but i
asked you are you friends with ralph and
you said yes i'm friends with ralph and
then you said i'm not friends with
me what the [ __ ] is wrong with you who
are you friends with are you friends
with ralph i'm just trying to keep score
no no obviously not are you friends
with ronnie i like i like ronnie if he
wants to be my friend i would be happy
to be friends with ronnie so i guess
that's the best way to put it he doesn't
want to be friends you're not friends
with him so you're not friends with him
now i turned the table on to me
it does i asked you are you friends with
ronnie are you
friends with ronnie and you're turning
the tables on him he's right
ralph is friends with chris chris is
friends with ralph
ralph is not friends with ronnie and
ronnie is not friends with
ralph and i also know and this is uh
shocking it's good to know even uh
ronnie's now 70 years old
high school never ends even at 70. it's
just same [ __ ]
for you kids out there
ronnie and i have mended uh the
relationship i believe yes i am
now friends again with ronnie ronnie are
you friends with chris
yeah we've talked okay chris and ronnie
are friends
ronnie's friends ralph and ronnie are
not friends
marianne from brooklyn is not friends
with chris but i think is friends with
ralph let me just double check that
yeah marianne you're friends with uh
ralph but not chris right he's an
acquaintance i'm not a friend but chris
your sex life all the stuff you spoke
about and you know what where's your
second sex
partners they haven't come back for more
you must be such a lousy stick sucker
that nobody cares i stay home
talk to him ralph anymore because he is
he's ruining you he's a bully in the
class
mariam from brooklyn is not friends with
uh chris
and she's an acquaintance of ralph she's
friends with ronnie
i know ralph's an acquaintance i'm just
a fan of the show
so what is chris michael rappaport who
are you fighting with
are you friends mike are you friends
with marianne
[Music]
it's bringing me so much joy and
optimism for for just my life in 2021
i've never heard that insult
but i i have to say marianne i'm bowing
down
here's what i know seems like marion and
michael rappaport are okay now
they bonded over the lousy dick sucker
thing uh
ralph and marianne are acquaintances
ralph and
and ronnie are not friends and ralph and
chris are friends
and chris and ronnie our friends and
chris and ronnie are friends there is
the update that you've all been waiting
for